[Music]
America's Got Talent faced some
technical difficulties during the show's
quarterfinals on Tuesday
this is ghostly what's happening at the
moment but that didn't stop the talent
from bringing it this is the best dance
group we seen in the live show so far
back in the Republic got rave reviews
from Simon Cowell during their
futuristic dance routine while the body
sounds duo jumbo dumped served up this
interesting number that almost got them
disqualified but possibly the redemption
routine of the entire season so far
goes to the Marion trapeze artists
Marion theis of duo transcend the couple
attempted they're dangerous blindfold
trick once again after suffering a
terrifying fall during the judge cuts
round earlier this season ET was with
Mary entice a backstage after the show
it took a lot of guts for her to get
back up there and trust me enough to do
that again so I'm proud of her she's got
she's so brave she's so powerful it's
just cool to that she's with me you know
listen brother I'm proud of you because
you didn't drop her yeah you didn't drop
[Music]